include this at the beginning of the
video this is me doing like the classic
YouTube like
you know
hey GQ I'm Finn wolfhard and today I'm
gonna go undercover on the internet
again
it's actually me
so Twitter is first
Finn wolfhard which character would you
like Mike to interact more in season
five I really miss doing scenes with
gate and Matarazzo plays Dustin like we
had a lot of students together in season
one he's like a old character actor he's
like Alan older or something like that I
feel like he's been 60 since he was like
12 years old so he's always really fun
and funny to act with and I love him so
I'd love to do more scenes with him the
next season
next I wonder if Finn wolfhard hates
Mike wheeler as much as the rest of us
for hurting will he's just such an idiot
I don't understand he's very very
Clueless yeah it was pretty
heartbreaking actually to do that scene
of just like how do you not understand
that your friend is struggling through
something yeah I don't know I don't use
the word hate I always try to forgive
the characters that I play so far so
good I haven't been like publicly
attacked yet for any of the roles that
I've played which is good only you know
only on the internet where you know it's
it's very easy to get
um called out I wonder which of the
characters in The Finn wolfhard
Cinematic Universe Finn wolfhard relates
to most would that be called an FCU the
FCU it sounds like a Wrestling
Federation or something like that I try
to at least relate to every character
that I'm playing as much as I can the
character that I've I feel like that
I've been felt the most like was maybe
like Richie from it because I just got
to joke around with my friends for a
whole summer and that's kind of what I
like to do and just be really obnoxious
generally so that was pretty that comes
comes easy to me I guess if I had a
nickel for every Time Finn wolfhard
starred in music videos playing a
younger version of a different band's
lead singer I'd have three nickels which
isn't a lot but it's weird that it's
happened to Thrice I like the use of
Thrice so I thank you for that first
yeah no it is really weird I the first
role that I ever had was for a Vancouver
local band called they're called facts
and I played the young version of uh of
the lead singer and then I was in two
videos for this punk band from Toronto
Club where I played the lead singer
again twice so I guess I just like look
like lead singers from bands or
something like that I guess I was
Typecast I'm surprised that I wasn't in
more posted Instagram
I can't believe season five will be the
final season crying crying crying what's
your favorite BTS stranger things memory
I hope you all stay friends crossfingers
Emoji two hearts spinning around and
then pray hands yeah I hope we all stay
friends too I don't think there's any
way for us not uh to stay friends
because we're kind of bonded forever I
would say I can't really believe that
it's the fifth season either by the time
it comes out I will be 22 I think and I
started working on the show at 12. that
is insane and uh I'll be able to drink
with Gayton and Caleb and Noah and the
whole cast at the premiere of stranger
things 5 which couldn't have said the
same thing she's at the season one
Premiere which blows my mind I mean
Netflix is gonna want us to come back in
10 years anyways and do like stranger
things the adult years or whatever so
they want they want to milk it they
wanna you know people wanna see it
and I do too I want to milk it as well
yo what Jesse Eisenberg movie I'm
intrigued I was also intrigued as well
and I was really happy to be a part of
the film and I'm a big fan of Jessie's
as a person and as a writer and so to be
able to work with them and you know
become friends with him has been
incredible he's one of the best people I
know
yeah you know it was really fun to be
able to also play music in the movie
because I could kind of hide behind the
guitar and feel a little more at home
while I was playing the uh playing the
role all right Reddit
do you think Mike will die in season
five I hope not or you know what I don't
know depends when if it's like one of
those things where it's like in the
first episode cold open no last episode
Mike saves everyone's life and it's like
oh yeah Mike you know everyone's like
cheering and shouting yes and you know
I'd do that maybe no I don't think he
will I mean maybe I should ask The
Duffer brothers because I want to know
if like I have a job next year
Finn wolfhard as young Severus Snape
thoughts this has 302 upvotes so I'll
let the fans decide there's an
interesting parallel though with my hair
that's about it I think I'm probably the
least Snape like person I'm not as
deadpan but maybe I could I don't know
we'll have to see you again we'll
consult the fans replied career
predictions for the stranger things cast
I think gayton's gonna be like an
unbelievable character actor I think
that like he's gonna keep going and
being on stage on Broadway I think Caleb
will be incredible uh dramatic actor as
he gets older and also a great
businessman he'll probably open a bunch
of I don't know restaurants raise a
restaurant he'll be like a restaurateur
or something like that David Harbor's
gonna move to the woods and no one's
gonna see him again he's gonna live in
this like weird little Shack and there's
a stranger things reunion we're all
gonna say where's David and someone will
say I haven't seen him in 40 years I
think everyone will sort of have a nice
next few years of their of their career
yeah oh Cora we're getting deeper into
the internet what are some stranger
things fun facts there's a few another
thing about getting Gayton was the first
person to get the part he found out that
he got the part of Dustin on the bus
ride home from the audition I didn't
find out till
five months later so I was the last one
cast Duffer Brothers there's that it was
originally supposed to be set in Long
Island and it got changed to the town of
Hawkins which is a fictional Town not a
lot of people like wanted the show like
they pitched it to like so many people
and no one said yes and Netflix was the
only people that said yes there was a
scene in season two where everyone is
together again at the buyer's house
Dustin's talking about something and Joe
keery just says his line is just the
Germans he was playing it so straight
and Charlie Heaton it was like a one had
to be a one take and every time he would
say that like Charlie would crack up and
it got to the point where like everyone
got so like the Denver brothers and like
David Harbor got so like mad at him that
they just were like you know what
Charlie's just not in the scene and we
were like what they're like yeah Charlie
I don't know like Charlie you gotta go
outside you're laughing too hard like
he's in the bathroom or something like
that like Jonathan just throw it away so
I think if you notice there's parts of
the scene where like they're very
obviously cutting around Charlie and he
breaks easily the most out of anyone
that I know I think on the show so that
was really really funny
how would you describe Finn wolfhard's
personal style oh man I'd like to see
the comments on this one
simple vintage stuff I don't know if
it's comfortable then I'll wear it but
yeah I like wearing like movie t-shirts
and band T-shirts and stuff like that
but sometimes I'll wear the same pair of
pants like for you know a month or
whatever which is actually kind of
disgusting nowadays I I respect people
that just go for Simplicity Jesse
Eisenberg he what I noticed yesterday is
that he's worn the same jacket and the
same Indiana University hat since 2020 I
think before that as well he wears the
same shirt every single day and the same
jacket every in the same hat which I
find uh great I respect him for it how
do I get Finn wolfhard to notice me post
something about him on the internet and
he might do one of those going
undercover on the internet they do on GQ
that is unbelievably meta you know
because it's an anonymous question I
hope you're watching and you finally got
your notice
yeah that's sweet YouTube
Market we should be the one that starts
the blooper reel
why is nobody talking about Finn's
British accent and how good it was he's
been hanging out with Charlie too much
yeah I feel like I unfairly made fun of
his accent a lot around him that's me
making fun of Charlie but not like in a
totally malicious way I try not to uh to
do that but we go into a lot of bits on
set to sort of keep us from not going
insane specifically that day we were
just in the desert in like 100 degree
heat driving around with no air
conditioning and so I mean you can see
Noah with the handheld fan that like
doesn't do anything yeah that's me
trying to make a joke and if you can
notice in the clip no one laughs that's
just day to day on set
hey GQ I'm Noah schnapp and I'm going
undercover on the internet do you think
Noah schnapp will be taller than Finn
wolfhard by the end of season 4. Finn's
tall I mean
I hope so I I won I want to be tall I
just want to be six feet tall
so far I think he hasn't he's not there
yet if he surpasses me then there's
gonna be a fight I think on set whoever
wins gets more screen time I mean even
in season one I think they're like
people are changing pretty rapidly
another shout out to Gayton his voice
changed halfway through filming I think
it's episode probably four his voice is
completely different if you go back you
can really really tell that his this
voice changed which is really funny I
guess that's just the nature of like
working with kids for uh extended period
of time
I may be the first to see him of
everybody oh my God Finn wolfhard in
Wednesday oh I saw this no
that's not me I did not travel to
Eastern Europe during covid to be in the
background of a shot of Wednesday I feel
like that would be kind of weird but
it does kind of look like me I weirdly I
feel like I have a lot of doppelgangers
anyone with like dark hair and bigger
eyes I feel like I could easily look
like but no I was not in Wednesday
I don't know why I said yet I probably
won't be in Wednesday but you know
cool oh Wikipedia let's see if they got
anything right or wrong
wolfhard also joined girono Toro stop
motion animated musical film Pinocchio
TV that was crazy
um and I'm really proud to be a part of
a film like that I auditioned for that
and I just for that a long time ago and
then I recorded in London once and then
through the pandemic and yeah it took a
long time I think they shot for a
thousand days it was really cool to see
it all come together and I was honored
to work with guiller notoro and be a
part of a film that has like that good
of a cast was really amazing as well one
of my favorite mediums for filmmaking in
general is stop motion I grew up like
watching you know all the Leica films
obviously but also night before
Christmas and my godmother is a an
animator and she started her career in
stop motion as well and so I grew up
sort of watching those sort of movies
um so I've always been a fan of them
wolfhard made his directorial debut with
the comedy short film night shifts yeah
I wrote this short for my friends
billion our tune and sort of wanted to
write something for them because I
thought they're really funny together
it's about a convenience store robbery
while we're shooting the sort of scene
where our tune the character of our tune
comes in and Rob's a convenience store
right behind our tune a real guy came in
to rob the convenience store and was
pointing a fake gun at the register and
everyone thought at the time that it was
real and I didn't see anything I was
just looking at my monitor but everyone
was sort of Frozen and my friend artoon
who had a fake gun as well like a prop
gun turned around and panicked and then
pointed his fake gun at the guy so they
were just at a fake gun standoff and
then the guy ended up just like walking
away and everyone was like what just
happened and and then we all just we
looked at our tune and we were like why
did you do that what if you had a real
gun he's like I don't know I panicked I
have no idea what I did so they had an
imaginary standoff while we were filming
a short film about a robbery okay that's
it I'm signing off the internet forever
[Music]